The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let
me just quickly remind
you of what we've done
what we did last time.
So unfortunately, today is going
to be a little bit of what I
wanted to do this time and a
little bit of what I would have
wanted to have been done
in recitation yesterday,
because all recitations
were cancelled.
So today is going to include
a few steps along the way
that I skipped over last time.
OK, so to review
from last time, we
talked about central potentials.
The energy operator had a radial
derivative term, an angular
momentum term, and
a potential term.
So this would be true regardless
of whether we were central
or not.
But if we have a central
potential, where this only
depends on the magnitude
of the radius vector,
then we can use
separation of variables,
and write an energy eigenstate
as a radial part-- which
we will sneakily pull out a
factor of 1 over the radius--
as we saw last time, that
was particularly convenient.
It took care of this r and made
everything nice and simple.
So a radial part times
a spherical harmonic.
The reason we use a
spherical harmonic is
that neither of these two
terms depend on the angular
coordinates.
The angular momentum, we know
what its eigenfunctions are,
so if we use a
spherical harmonic,
this angular momentum
becomes just a constant.
And having separated
in this form,
and pulling out that
sneaky factor of 1 over r,
the energy eigenvalue equation
reduces to a simple 1-D
effective energy
eigenvalue equation
with a simple dr squared,
and an effective potential,
where the effective potential is
the original central potential
plus an angular
momentum term, often
referred to the angular
momentum barrier-- which
is proportional
to-- as Matt says,
as Professor Evans
says, in 804, one
is forced to say h bar
squared upon 2m repeatedly.
And he pointed out that it would
be much more efficient if I
would just come up with a
simple variable for saying it
or sound.
So I will attempt to
henceforth call it pfft.
[LAUGHTER]
So the effective
potential is pfft,
l, l plus 1 upon r squared
plus the central part
of the potential-- props
to Professor Evans.
And this is true in general
for central potential.
The last thing we notice of
this is that since the energy
eigenvalue equation has been
reduced to this form, which
depends on l, but is
independent of m-- m
appears nowhere here--
the energy can't possibly
depend on m, although
it can depend on l.
It's just e of l.
And thus, for every
different value of m,
I will get the same energy--
fixed l, different m.
And there are how many
values of m for a fixed l?
2l plus 1.
So the degeneracy
of El is 2l plus 1.
Right?
That's general for
any central potential.
It only requires
spherical symmetry.
So then we say the example of
the cooling potential, where
the potential is minus
E squared upon r.
And we solved-- or I quickly
reviewed the solution
of the energy
eigenvalue equation.
I'll write it that
way-- where r of what
I will call-- in place of
E I, will simply write n.
Rnl is equal to e to
the minus r over 2
r naught n times r over r
naught to the l plus 1 times
some simple function v sub
n of l of r over r naught,
with the energy nlm
being equal to E naught--
or I should say e Rydberg in
our notation of last time--
upon n squared
minus bound state.
So let's talk
about this quickly.
This term-- the fact that it
goes exponentially-- falls
exponentially at
large distances--
came from the asymptotic
analysis at r goes to infinity.
And this is just saying
it's a bound state.
The probability density
falls off exponentially
as we get to large radius.
This term came from
the asymptotic analysis
near r goes to zero.
And near r goes to
zero, the only term
that matters is in the
effective-- this is one upon r.
This is 1 over r squared, so
this gets large more rapidly.
This term is important,
and that l, l plus 1
gave us r to the l plus 1.
We work in dimensionless
variables, rho.
And here, I replace rho
with r over r naught,
where r naught was the
characteristic scale
we computed last time.
And finally, this
function V sub nl
satisfied-- it again satisfied
the energy eigenvalue equation,
but having pulled
out these factors
such that asymptotically,
its regular.
So this function
must be regular,
smooth-- no
divergences, no poles--
as r goes to infinity and to 0.
OK.
And then we solved this
by series expansion.
And from termination of
the series expansion,
we got that the energy--
we got a relationship
between the energy
and l and n, and
in particular the
relationship-- this
came from termination
of the series, just
like it did for the
harmonic oscillator.
And the termination
series gave us
that the energy was equal
to minus a constant over n
squared.
With one additional
condition, which
is that n had to
be greater than l.
n had to be an integer
greater than l.
And l, of course, has to be
greater than or equal to 0.
So let me just
quickly tell you how
this arises, because this is an
important fact about hydrogen
which I want you to understand.
So the way that arises is we
got the energy from a series
expansion for this remaining
function of rv and l of r.
And that series
expansion started out
by saying let v be of the
form sum over j of a sub j, r
over r naught, the dimensionless
variable rho, to the j,
to the j-th power, so
it's a power series.
And when we plug this
whole form, together
with this series expansion,
into that differential equation,
we get-- just like we did before
for a harmonic oscillator--
we get a set of
relations between
the various coefficients
in that series.
And we solve that by
saying a sub j plus 1--
by deriving a recursion
relation-- is equal to a sub
j times 2, square
root of epsilon times
j plus l plus 1 minus 1 upon
j plus 1, j plus 2l plus 2.
OK, fine.
We get this recursion relation.
It looks absolutely
awful, but it tells you
that if you know a0, say, is
a constant which is not 0--
if it's zero, then
they're all 0-- then
this function is identically
0, because a j plus 1
is a j times some constant.
So this had better
not vanish-- a sub 0.
So the first term,
the constant term
doesn't vanish, which is good.
It tells us V doesn't
vanish, so we've already
learned something.
If V doesn't vanish
identically at the origin,
then we can determine a1 from
a0 by multiplying by this.
j is 0 in this, and
l is whatever number
we fix from ylm.
And so on.
We can deduce all
the higher a sub l's.
It's a series expansion.
This is the recursion
relation for it.
However, note the following
thing-- as j gets large,
so we go to higher and
higher orders in the series,
then j is much larger than
whatever fixed number l is,
and much larger than
whatever fixed number 2 is.
So this asymptotes to aj times
roughly 2 epsilon j upon j
plus 1 j.
At very large j, this just
goes to 2 epsilon over j.
Now, let's think
about what that means.
If I have that aj plus
1 is roughly equal
to aj times root epsilon
times 2 over j plus 1,
I guess, then this tells me
that every time I increase j,
I get a factor of j plus 1
and another factor of 2 root
epsilon.
This tells me that a sub j
is equal to a sub 0 times
2 root epsilon to the
j over j factorial.
But those are the
expansion coefficients
of an exponential-- quantity
to the n over n factorial.
But that's bad, because
if this series is
the exponential series with
argument 2 root epsilon,
then this series becomes E to
the 2 root epsilon r over r0.
But that's bad, because that
would exactly swamp this term.
That would defeat the
asymptotic analysis
we did at the beginning.
If this term, V, is
growing so large twice
as rapidly as this
is going to 0,
then the net is
diverging at infinity.
That's bad.
So in order for this--
for the series expansion--
to describe a good function that
really does vanish at infinity,
we need that this
doesn't happen.
So it must be true
that j doesn't
get large enough that
the exponential in V
overwhelms the
decaying exponential
from the asymptotic analysis.
Everyone cool with that?
So it has to terminate.
But if it terminates-- let's
look at the coefficient here.
If it terminates, this says that
2 root epsilon times j plus--
and if it terminates, that says
that there's some j maximum.
Well, let me write it over here.
If it terminates,
that means there's
some value j such
that aj plus 1 is 0.
But if aj plus 1 is zero,
how can that possibly be?
It must be that for
that maximum value of j,
the numerator
vanishes-- specifically
for that maximum value of j.
Yeah?
Well, what's the condition
for that numerator
to vanish for a
specific value of j?
I'll j sub m, or j
max, the maximum value,
such that a sub j
max plus 1 vanishes.
So j plus l plus 1
must be equal to 1.
Or said differently,
epsilon-- which
is the energy in units
of e0, must be equal to 1
over 4 g max plus l plus
1, quantity squared.
Cool?
So that means that our
solutions, or states psi,
are now labeled
by three integers.
they're labeled by l And by
m from spherical harmonics,
but they're also labeled
by the value j max.
And j max can be any number
from 0 to infinity, right?
Strictly, it
shouldn't be infinite,
but any finite number, any
countable, any integer--
because eventually the
series terminates at j max.
So it's labeled by
these three numbers,
and the energy of lmj max
is equal to e0 minus over 4.
And this e0 over 4 we already
saw was e Rydberg, 13.6 dv,
times what value?
Well, here's the energy in
units of e0-- jm plus l plus 1,
quantity squared.
Where L is greater
than or equal to 0,
j sub m is greater than
or equal to 0, and 1 is 1.
But this is sort of cumbersome.
We can just as well
call this quantity n,
where n is greater
than l as an integer.
It can't be equal
to l, but it could
be 1 greater than l,
or any greater integer.
Is that cool?
So instead of labeling
it by jm, the point
at which the series terminates,
we'll label it by n,
and you can deduce what jm is
by subtracting I plus 1 from n.
That tells you where
the series terminates.
Notice that this tells
you something nice.
This power series for V,
if n is equal to l plus 1,
has how many terms in it?
So say it out loud, just
think about it a second.
If n is equal to l
plus 1, how many terms
are there, that are
non-vanishing in the power
series?
I won't call on you,
but raise your hand
when you have an answer.
What's the value of j max
if n is equal to l plus 1?
So what term is the first
one to vanish in the series?
OK, so how many terms
are non-vanishing?
Yeah, just the one--
just the first term.
So when l is as large
as it can possibly
be-- when l is equal to n minus
1, V is a constant function.
It's just constant.
When l is one less, when l is
n minus 1, or n is l plus 2,
then V has two terms in it--
a constant, and a linear.
So the greater the
difference between l and n,
the more terms there
are in the series.
OK?
So anyway, this leads to
this form of the energy.
But as is usually the case, this
sort of a brute force analysis
doesn't give us a
whole lot of insight
into why we get the
qualitative features we do.
In particular, the
qualitative feature
that stands out most obviously
to me-- I don't know about you
guys-- is the fact that
the degeneracy is now much,
much larger.
In particular, we know
from basic principles
of a central potential--
as we just reviewed--
that anytime a potential
is symmetrically invariant,
is spherically
symmetric-- any time
the potential is spherically
symmetric, rotationally
invariant-- then there
must be degeneracy
of 2l plus 1 for every energy
eigenstate-- there must be.
The l could be zero, but if
there's any angular momentum,
then that degeneracy
must be 2l plus 1.
But this is much
more degenerate.
And in fact, how
degenerate is it?
Well, for any given
En, the degeneracy
is equal to-- well, what are
the possible values of l?
So we have some state for
every different value of l.
l could be equal to 0, and it
can go up to n minus 1, right?
Because, again,
n is some integer
which could vanish, l plus 1.
So as small as this can be is 0.
So n can be l plus 1,
or anything greater.
I.e.: l can go up to n minus
1, but it can't be any greater.
Then for every value of
l, there is a state n--
there's a value of n which
could be minus l all the way up
to l in integer steps.
So how many states are there?
Well there's one state for
every value of n, l, and m.
So it's this sum.
The sum on m for minus
l to l is 2l plus 1.
So this is the sum n minus
1, l equals 0, of 2l plus 1.
And this is equal to,
kind of beautifully, n
squared-- just
arithmetic series.
So we have this huge
degeneracy, which
is much larger than 2l plus 1.
It's the sum over 2l plus
1 from l to 0 to n minus 1.
Where is this
degeneracy coming from?
Why?
So quantum mechanically,
we know the following--
we've learned the
following-- and I
hope it's under your
fingernails at this point--
that when you see
a degeneracy, you
should expect that degeneracy
to follow from some symmetry.
There's some symmetry
of the system that
is leading to a degeneracy
by virtue of the fact
that the generators of that
symmetry-- for example,
for rotation it's
angular momentum--
commute with the energy.
And when you have an operator
that commutes with the energy
operator, as we've
seen, you can generally
construct new states given
a single energy eigenstate
by acting suitably
with that operator.
So we should expect there
to be some new symmetry.
But it's very hard
to see what symmetry.
I mean, this is hydrogen.
This is central potential.
It's just some stupid
central potential.
What's so special about
the hydrogen system as
opposed to, for example,
the harmonic oscillator?
Which hopefully you will see
in recitation at some point.
The harmonic oscillator
in three dimensions
has degeneracy 2l plus 1.
It's a central potential.
It has to have degeneracy 2l
plus 1-- but not n squared.
Where did that come from?
What's so special about
the Kepler problem?
So there must be some
symmetry, but it's not obvious
what it is.
But now let's use a note
from classical mechanics.
Noether's Theorem tells us
when we have a symmetry,
we have a conserved quantity.
We also saw this in the
quantum mechanical version
for expectation values.
We have a conserved quantity.
And in quantum mechanics,
having a conserved quantity
means that the energy
commutes with some quantity.
Because that controls
the time evolution
of the expectation value.
So there must be
some quantity, which
I've written by a question mark,
that commutes with the energy
operator, specifically
in the case
of the harmonic oscillator.
So what is that quantity?
So actually, this quantity
in classical mechanics
was studied, because
the same thing
is true in the Kepler case.
In the Kepler case,
the orbits close,
and they have simple
ellipses, and they
have all sorts of
nice properties
that beg for an explanation
in terms of symmetry.
And it was pointed out by a
number of people-- Laplace,
Runge, Lenz, various
people-- and this is often
called the Runge-Lenz
vector, but I
think you can blame it
on any number of people--
that there's a vector that
in classical mechanics,
for the Kepler problem--
or for the Coulomb problem,
is conserved.
And that quantity is p cross
l-- momentum cross angular
momentum-- minus m
e squared-- and let
me write m sub electrons--
it's the mass rather
than the quantum number little
m-- e squared, r vector.
So it turns out this quantity
is classically conserved,
and if you make a quantum
operator out of it,
then e with A is equal to 0.
Add hat.
This was enormously non-obvious.
If it's obvious to
you, you're a freak.
It's really, really not obvious.
You can go through and
do the calculation.
And when I say really not
obvious, I mean-- well,
I'll show you what I
mean in just a second.
So you can go through and do
the calculation classically.
Is this quantity conserved
in the Kepler problem
using Newton's law?
And the answer is yes.
It's amazing.
Quantum mechanically, you
can do the same thing.
But I'm going to warn you for
anyone who has the chutzpah
to try-- because I
encourage you to,
but it takes a
little bit of brawn--
think about this
operator for second.
Does this classical quantity
have an obvious interpretation
as a quantum operator?
No, because l is r cross p.
But now we have prp.
There's an ordering ambiguity.
So you have to decide
which order do you
put that p and that r, and
the other p-- ppr, rpr,
prr-- right?
You can write out which
components you mean here.
For example, you mean
for the z component of a,
you're going to get
px ly, and ly px.
But within that, how do you
order the p's and the r's,
because ly contains px, and
in particular, it contains x.
So there's an
ordering ambiguity.
So just be a little bit
careful about this as a quantum
mechanical operator if
you do play with this.
But if you do it, and
you're thoughtful about it,
it's pretty easy to see that
it can be computed and checked
that, in fact, the
commutator vanishes.
So at this point, it's
tempting to say, aha!
There's an extra
conserved quantity.
We declare victory.
The problem is, this didn't
give us the symmetry.
This just told us there's
a conserved quantity.
What's the symmetry behind this?
What's the symmetry
that insures that this
is a conserved quantity?
It's obviously not rotations.
It's something else.
And so there are many
answers to this question.
One answer involves an explicit
expression for in phase space,
the change of
variables dx-- and this
is a variation that
depends on f of x and p.
So there's a little
vector parameter,
and the change of the
physical coordinates
depends on both the
coordinates and the momenta.
This is a slightly
strange thing,
because it's like a
change of variables
where the position gets mapped
into some non-linear function
of the positions and momenta.
That's a little bit weird,
but you can do this.
But I don't find it a
terribly satisfying answer.
And here's the answer I find
most satisfying-- it's not
terribly useful for
our present purposes,
but you're going to run
into this again in 805, when
you do what's called the
operator method for the Coulomb
potential, and it
turns out to be
an enormously useful machine.
We're not going
to use it in 804,
but I want to
advertise it for you.
I want to give you a
description, though,
that isn't the description
you're going to get in 805.
The description is
the following-- 1935,
guy named Fock,
crazy guy, amazing,
amazing physicist--
played a huge role
in the development of
quantum field theory.
I'm not exactly sure why he was
thinking about this problem,
but he was, and this was a
very sort of Soviet thing
to do at the time, I guess, to
be hard core and mathematical.
So off he was going,
computing things,
and he observed the
following fact--
how he observed this,
again, crazy long story.
He observed the following fact--
if you take a Kepler problem
and you work in momentum
space-- so you write everything
in terms of the momentum--
it turns out that the Kepler
problem, or he referred
to as the Kepler problem,
but I'll refer to it as
the Coulomb problem in 3D,
three spatial dimensions--
this is really crazy--
is exactly equivalent.
There's a change of variables--
it's kind of complicated,
but it's just a
projection, it turns out.
It's exactly equivalent to
the problem of a free particle
in four dimensions,
constrained to the surface
of a sphere-- to a three
sphere in four dimensions.
So you take a three
You take a marble.
You kick it, but make sure
that it's stuck to the sphere.
It will move in
perfect circles, right?
Obviously-- it's
moving on a sphere,
it's just going to
move in great circles.
OK, that's nice and simple.
What's the symmetry
group of that system?
Well, the sphere is
invariant under any rotation
in four dimensions.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ah, SO4--
there's a symmetry SO4--
special orthogonal
transformation.
Special means it
doesn't change length.
Orthogonal means
that it's a rotation.
So it's orthogonal rotations
in four dimensions,
and so now, this
should sound familiar,
because the angular
momentum group in 3D is SO3.
It's rotations that don't change
the length in three dimensions.
OK?
How many elements does it have?
How many conserved quantities
go along with this?
Well, how many conserved
quantities go along
with rotations in
three dimensions?
What's conserved by virtue of
rotational invariance in three
dimensions?
Angular momentum-- how many
components of angular momentum
are there?
Three, right, there are three.
So it turns out that
if you calculate in SO4
how many conserved quantities
are there, there are six.
And when you do this
mapping back down
from the free particle in 4D
to the Coulomb problem in 3D,
three of them are the l's,
and the other three of them
are this A vector--
comes out spot on.
So what it's telling you is
that the spectrum of hydrogen--
or at least the I
shouldn't say of hydrogen,
the spectrum of the
Coulomb system--
has an enhanced symmetry.
It's the symmetry group of
rotations in four dimensions.
Why?
I don't know, it's
just kind awesome.
But I think that's about
the best that can be said.
It's just true.
So for certain very
special potentials,
we find that this
sort of thing happens.
It happens in
other systems, too.
You discover that there
are accidental symmetries
in your system.
They shouldn't be referred
to as accidental symmetries.
They are enormously
nontrivial functions
of the rest of the
system, and we're
going to break the
symmetry in a minute,
and you'll see why we shouldn't
refer to it as accidental.
But in any case, the
answer to the question,
why do we have this giant
degeneracy in the Coulomb
problem-- why is it n squared
rather than 2l plus 1--
is that there is an
enhanced symmetry group.
There's more symmetry then
you would have thought.
And there's a conserved
quantity associated with it.
And that conserved
quantity corresponds
quantum mechanically
to an operator
that commutes with
the energy operator.
OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Indeed, indeed.
AUDIENCE: So how do you get
three conserved components
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
What do I mean in classical
mechanics for a quantity
to be conserved?
I mean that the time rate
of change of that quantity,
under the classical dynamics,
under classical evolution,
is preserved.
So what's the quantum
mechanical version of that?
So the mechanical
version of that is, well,
can we say that d dt
of some operator--
or of some observable a is 0.
Does this makes sense?
No, because it turns out,
in the language we've
been using-- in the Schrodinger
evolution description
that we've been using--
this doesn't really
make sense, because this
thing is an operator.
That's not a quantity.
Quantity is something
you measure.
So what do you measure?
Do you measure the operator?
In a state, you measure
its expectation values.
You might measure
its eigenvalues,
but the more general thing
is expectation values.
So this is something
that depends on time,
because the wave function
depends on time-- psi of t.
OK, so the best to say
something is conserved,
is to say d dt of A is 0.
But we've seen
what the condition
is for the expectation
value to not change in time.
In general, for any
operator A, the time rate
of change of its
expectation value
is given by the
commutator of E with A.
I can do the symbols-- good.
OK, so in particular, if
this commutator vanishes,
if the commutator vanishes--
equals 0--, this is equal to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
Well, the wave function
can be time variant,
and I'm going to
assume for the moment
that the energy operator
and the A operator are not,
themselves, explicitly
time dependent.
Yes, that's an
important assumption.
So let me just
assume for simplicity
that neither the energy nor the
operator A that I'm looking at
are explicitly time dependent.
Like, it shouldn't
be, like, x plus tp.
That would be annoying.
So let me assume that
that's not the case.
You do have to deal
with that sometimes.
For example, if you are
dealing with a system that
changes in time, where there's
a background magnetic field,
or something like that,
that changes in time.
But module that sort of detail.
And also, there's an i h bar,
so where do the i h bars go?
Do the units make sense here?
A, A, good.
E and d dt-- whoops.
So where do the i h bars go?
Well, it can go on either side.
You have to tell me
if they go up or down.
What is the
Schrodinger equation?
Yeah, exactly, i h bar,
OK so we need an i h bar.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, this spring
has got to us all.
So now, in the case
that e with A as 0,
imagine we have an operator
a that commutes equal to 0.
Then d dt of the expectation
value of A in any state
is equal to 0.
And that's what
I'll call conserved.
So classically, to be
a conserved quantity
means that it's
time independent.
Quantum mechanically, to
be a conserved quantity
means that it commutes
with the energy.
Now, going back to the
question-- the question was,
look for angular momentum.
There are only two numbers you
can know at any moment in time.
You can't know three.
You can know the total
angular momentum, little l.
And you can know
the angular momentum
in a particular direction,
which we conventionally
call z-- little n, right?
But you can't know some
other angular momentum,
like angular momentum in x
direction simultaneously.
So what does it mean
to say that there
are three conserved quantities?
I can't know three conserved
quantities at the same time.
They're not even well defined
at some moment in time.
The answer is there are
three operators-- lx,
and ly, and lz--
which I will simply
write as l vector-- all of
which commute with E. So
while it's true that
systems don't have
definite values of lx,
ly and lz simultaneously,
nonetheless lx, ly
and lz all commute
with the energy operator.
And as a consequence, their
time expectation values
are all 0 in a
central potential.
So the time derivatives
of their expectation
are all 0s in a
central potential.
They're all constant
in a central potential.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You mean 1 over r?
STUDENT: Yeah, 1 over r.
PROFESSOR: So the question is,
if you don't have 1 over r,
do you get extra-special
things that
happen for other
potentials that aren't
1 over r, but something else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's not
quite a unique case.
So the question is-- this
is a very good question.
So the question is this-- this
is a great question-- look,
there's something peculiar
about 1 over r classically.
The orbit's closed.
You get ellipses.
You don't get
progressing ellipses.
That's what you get if
you have an n harmonic.
If you have an extra 1 over r
to the sixth term, or something,
a small correction
to 1 over r, which we
do in the real solar system.
It's a many body system
instead of a two-body system,
so r orbit doesn't close.
It's close, but--
so that's special.
And here we see that there's
an enhanced symmetry.
Are these things
related to each other?
So the answer is almost,
in the following sense--
for the harmonic oscillator,
we also have it close,
but there isn't a
Runge-Lenz vector.
However, the orbits
close, so there's
something special
about that one, too.
Is there a conserved
quantity there?
And it turns out the
answer to that is yes.
There's an enhanced
symmetry there as well.
But it's not like this.
It doesn't lead to this
gigantic degeneracy.
There is just extra
structure that's
nice about the
harmonic oscillator.
But for the harmonic oscillator,
of course, it also closes.
It's not this orbits this.
So there's a nice
structure there,
but it's not quite so simple.
OK, yeah, one last question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Kepler's problem.
I was wondering if it's at all
correct thinking [INAUDIBLE]
symmetry or
degeneracy [INAUDIBLE]
equal time instead
of equal area?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's not unrelated.
I don't know how to make
that connection sharp,
but the thing I can say sharp--
so the question is, look,
is that conserved quantity
somehow related to the fact
that there's equal time in
equal-- equal areas swept out
in equal time at all
points in the orbit?
Which is a true thing
about a Kepler problem.
That's a good observation.
I don't know how to
make that connection,
but it is true in
the following sense--
that both of those facts
are guaranteed by the fact
that you have closed orbits
with a particular ratio.
And that is, indeed,
can be blamed
on the conservation of
the Runge-Lenz vector.
I don't know how to make that
connection direct and explicit,
but indeed it is.
So that's fun question.
I'll have to think about that.
That's a good one.
One of the totally awesome
things about teaching 804
is that every
single time, someone
asks a question I've
never even thought
of before-- forget
never answered.
Never even thought of.
I never thought of that.
It's a great question.
OK, so everyone cool
with the degeneracy?
We have this
gigantic degeneracy.
So knowing what the degeneracy
is, or where it's coming from,
at least more or
less-- is progress.
But if you really understand
why something is conserved,
then you can break
that conservation.
You can break that degeneracy.
So here's my question,
is it possible-- can
we, or indeed must we, can we
break or lift this degeneracy?
So first, let me tell you
what those words mean.
So we have this
gigantic degeneracy
of the n squared of
the Coulomb potential.
Can we break that
degeneracy or lift it?
What I mean by lift the
degeneracy, what I mean by lift
the degeneracy is
the following--
suppose I have a system
that's degenerate,
so it's got two
energy eigenstates
with the same energy eigenvalue.
So this is energy.
Then if I can kick the
system in some way,
or modify it, or bend it such
that the energy levels are
no longer to
degenerate, one state
has been lifted above the other.
And so we use the word
to lift a degeneracy.
Now you can see that
they're two different states
by measuring the energies.
It's also said to
split a degeneracy,
or to break a degeneracy.
So those are just words.
OK, so can we break or
lift this degeneracy?
So sure.
How do we break a degeneracy?
How do we lift a degeneracy?
We need to break the symmetry.
So if we don't
have the symmetry,
we won't get the degeneracy.
We've seen this before.
So first off, let's
think about what
are the two symmetries
that we want?
Well, we got this
degeneracy of 2l plus 1
from spherical symmetry.
And we got this extra degeneracy
of n squared from conservation
of the Runge-Lenz vector.
And conservation of
the Runge-Lenz vector
came from the fact that we had
exactly the Coulomb system.
So anything that isn't
exactly the Coulomb system,
but is still
rotationally invariant,
should still have the
2l plus 1 degeneracy,
but not the n
squared degeneracy--
like the harmonic
oscillator, for example.
So let's change the system.
Let's find a small correction
to the system that leaves it
mostly the Coulomb problem,
but with some small correction.
So what comes to mind?
So one good way to think
about a physical, natural way
to break this degeneracy,
to break the symmetry,
is to think a real system
that's described by the Coulomb
potential.
So the system that we usually
talk about is hydrogen.
Hydrogen is the proton.
It's got a plus charge,
and it's got electron.
And it's attractive with
a minus E squared upon r.
So in hydrogen, is this the
energy operator for hydrogen?
Is this a good description
of the energy operator
for hydrogen?
It's a good start, but
it's not exactly right,
for a bunch of reasons.
And in fact, in your
first problem set,
when you computed the time
it takes for hydrogen,
classically, to decay from
the classical Bohr radius,
one of the things you discovered
is that the electron starts out
being non-relativistic, but very
rapidly becomes relativistic.
And rapidly is 10 to
the minus 15 seconds.
This is a non-relativistic, p
squared upon 2m kinetic energy.
That's probably not a
perfect approximation.
So the first example is going
to be relativistic corrections.
Now, will relativistic
corrections
break rotational symmetry?
They can't, because
relativity doesn't say,
this is the z direction.
In fact, it does
quite the opposite.
Relativity, among
other things, says,
don't get too hung up on
what's the z direction.
But relativistic corrections
will not break the symmetry.
So if we include
relativistic corrections
to the kinetic energy,
this will change E,
change the energy operator.
But it will preserve
the rotational symmetry.
E with l is equal to 0.
So we won't break this
rotational symmetry,
so we'll preserve the 2l plus 1.
So let's check to see
that this is true.
So to check to see
that this is true,
let's actually estimate out
the correction to the energy
due to the first nontrivial
relativistic effect
in the atom.
The first nontrivial,
relativistic effect
can be calculated
[INAUDIBLE] kinetic energy
in special relativity,
of a particle of mass m.
So that's easy.
It's the total energy is
the square root of m squared
c to the 4th plus p squared
c squared minus mc squared.
That's the rest energy.
That's the total energy, so
this is the kinetic energy.
But this is equal to--
well, if we pull out
a factor of m squared
c squared, this
is m c squared times the square
root of 1 plus p squared over n
squared c squared minus 1.
And now if we
Taylor expand this--
because if the momentum is small
compared to mc squared-- or mc,
I should say-- the momentum is
small compared to mc which is,
morally speaking,
at low velocity is,
the velocity is
small compared to c,
then this is 1 plus
a small number,
and we can Taylor expand this to
get 1 plus 1/2 a small number.
And the 1s will cancel,
giving us only 1/2.
So this is going to be equal
to 1/2 of that small number,
p squared over m
squared c squared,
times mc squared
upstairs, giving us
the first term, which
is p squared upon 2m.
That's the familiar
classical kinetic energy.
Rock on.
What's next correction?
The next correction is the next
term for this Taylor series,
which is going to involve
this quantity squared,
so it's going to be p to
the 4th over m to the 4th, c
the 4th times mc to the 4th.
The coefficient is a minus
1/8, so we get minus p
to the 4th over 8m
cubed c squared.
And that's down by a
factor of m squared
c squared from this
guy, n of p squared
upstairs-- which is
what you'd get-- p
squared m squared,
over c squared, OK?
So the correction to the kinetic
energy for a given momentum p
is to correct it down
by p to the 4th term.
Everyone cool with that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why do you make
the assumption [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Because
you, like Schrodinger,
did problem Set One.
And problem Set One said, if
you have an electron at the Bohr
radius classically, its
velocity is about 1/400
of the speed of light.
200?
It's small.
It's a couple of
orders of magnitude
smaller than the speed of light.
So that number, that ratio
there, is 1 upon 200,
or 400-- I don't
remember-- squared.
That's a very small
number, so it's
a reasonable approximation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Because what
is the typical-- that's
an excellent question.
So why am I talking about
it as if the electron
is sitting at that radius?
And the answer is, well, look--
what is the average momentum?
What is the average
value of p squared in,
let's say, the ground
state of the hydrogen atom?
What's the average value of p?
What must be the
average value of p
in the ground state
of the hydrogen atom?
Zero on two grounds--
first off, p is a vector,
and the ground state of hydrogen
is rotationally invariant.
It doesn't break anything.
Secondly, it's not
going anywhere.
It's a bound state, so
it's just sitting there.
It's got an average
momentum of 0.
If it carried momentum,
it would be cruising.
So it's got average momentum 0.
OK, fine, but what's the
average momentum squared?
What's the average of p squared?
We can actually do
out that calculation.
You're going to have to do that
calculation on the problem set.
And it's a small number.
And it's, in fact,
almost exactly what
you'd guess classically
from the Bohr radius.
So you have to know the
h bar to compute the Bohr
radius in the first place.
So the answer is, to the
best of anyone's ability
to define what's the
momentum, or the typical scale
of momentum, that
typical scale of momentum
for the electron in the
ground state of hydrogen
is extraordinarily small
compared to the speed of light
by a factor of 100, 200, or 400.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: It's a
very good question.
OK, so here's the
kinetic energy.
And by the way,
another way to say
that this approximation
must be good
is that we've already
computed-- ignoring
the relativistic correction--
we computed the ground
state of energy,
and it was 13.6 Ev,
which is pretty good, since
the binding energy of hydrogen
is about 13.6 Ev.
So apparently, that was
a good approximation.
And you might be disgusted
by answer analysis like that,
but that's what physics is.
You write down some
stupid, cockamamie model
that you know is
wrong, but if it
does a good job of fitting
the data, you declare triumph,
and you call Stockholm.
[LAUGHTER]
So it depends on the
problem you've just
solved approximately.
So here's the first correction.
And now, what this
tells us is therefore,
the energy of
hydrogen-- or at least
a better model of
hydrogen-- I'll
call it hydrogen tilde--
is equal to E Coulomb
minus p to the 4th over
8m cubed c squared.
OK so this, however, we
know is small compared
to the kinetic energy, because
13.6 is pretty close to 13.6.
Notice I didn't include the
rest of the significant digits.
So this must be in the
insignificant digits.
So this must be small.
So here's what I
want to ask-- we
know that the energy of
the Coulomb problem, nlm,
is equal to e0 squared
minus e0 squared
over n squared,
independent of l and m.
What's the energy in this
toy model of hydrogen
that includes the first
relativistic correction-- nlm.
Well, to answer that question
we have to resolve the energy
eigenvalue equation, right?
We have to refined the
energy eigenstates,
and we have to solve that.
And this is going to be a much
worse problem, because it's
going to involve a p
to the 4th term, which
is going to involve
four derivatives.
That sounds horrible.
Can anyone think of a better
way to just approximate,
estimate the magnitude and the
value of the leading correction
from this quantity?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Some variation
on take an eigenvalue,
plug it in, see
what the error is,
correct for that error--
something like that.
PROFESSOR: There's an iterative
method for doing that.
It's a very good guess, but
there's an even easier way
to estimate it.
That's something we will
call perturbation theory when
we do this in 805.
And doing that systematically
is exactly the right answer.
However I want you to do just
the leading part of that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Dimensional analysis.
PROFESSOR: Oh, dimensional
analysis would be awesome.
That's fantastic, brilliant.
So how would you compute p?
OK, so we didn't calculate p.
You can do a
dimensional analysis
and get a p, because
you have an e,
you have an l, you
can probably do it.
But here's the
problem with that,
though-- this is the correct
first answer to any question
of this kind--
correct first answer
is plug in dimensional
analysis, and get an estimate
for the order of magnitude.
But we want more than the
order of magnitude here.
We're interested in
splitting the degeneracy
due to this interaction.
So what that means is we want
to see that different values
use of l lead to
different energy.
What we care about
is the l dependence
that comes out of
this correction.
And we're not going to be
able to get the l dependence
from dimensional analysis,
because l is an integer.
It is dimensionless.
Yeah, so that will give
you the correct magnitude,
and that is the
first thing you do.
What's the second thing you do?
AUDIENCE: Stick in
the expectation value
of p to the 4th.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
Let's just stick in the
expectation value p to the 4th.
That's not exactly
the right thing to do,
but if this is small, that's
probably pretty reasonable.
And what you'll find when you
do it systematically using
perturbation theory, as
was pointed out earlier,
we can take the entire system,
the entire energy eigenvalue
equation-- we can
think of this 1 over m
cubed c squared
as a small number,
and we can do perturbation
theory on that small number.
We can Taylor expand everything
in that small number.
And when you Taylor expand
the exact equation, what
you discover is the leading
term in that Taylor expansion
is the expectation value
p to the 4th over 8m cubed
c squared.
OK, so this is a
fantastic guess.
OK, so let's compute it.
So E hydrogen is going to be
equal to E nlm, which I'm just
to write as minus
E0 over m squared.
OK, so what is the
correct answer here?
So it's this quantity
minus-- so this
is making it more tightly bound.
Notice the sign,
because p to the 4th
is strictly positive
if p is real.
So minus E0 over m
squared, and if you go out
and you do this expectation
value, which I really
should have put on the
problem set-- oh, I still can.
It hasn't been posted yet, so
it'll be posted this afternoon.
But I won't.
It's not that bad, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
Matt, what do you think?
AUDIENCE: No!
[LAUGHS]
PROFESSOR: We'll discuss
this afterwards, OK?
Which may or may not
appear on your problem set.
So if you go ahead and you do
this calculation, what you find
is the correction is En
squared, so E0 squared over n
to the 4th-- this time it
really is n to the 4th--
and now you have to worry
about dimensional analysis.
This is two energies.
We want one energy, divided
by-- wait for it-- mc squared,
because it's a
relativistic correction.
That shouldn't be
too surprising.
Times the quantity
4n over-- and here
where life gets awesome--
l plus 1/2 minus 3.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: You laugh,
but I feel delighted
by this for so many reasons.
One is, that's beautiful.
What a crazy
combination of symbols.
But the second
and more important
one is, look it has an l in it,
and the l is downstairs, right?
That's good.
It has more leverage that way.
But so we've got
this l appearing,
so the energy depends on l.
Good, we've broken
the degeneracy.
Different values of l
give different energies.
So let's do that graphically.
So in particular,
what this tells
us is that now while the
Coulomb energy commuted
with the Runge-Lenz
vector, it must be true
that the energy of
this model of hydrogen,
which includes the first
relativistic correction,
does not commute with
the Runge-Lenz vector.
And indeed, if you
check this-- which
is effortful, but
not intellectually
difficult-- indeed,
it doesn't vanish.
And the failure of this
conservation equation,
the failure this commutational
relation to vanish,
tell us that it's
possible for the system
to not be degenerate.
And lo and behold,
it is not degenerate.
OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I just wanted
to clarify something that--
did you say before that the
actual first term when you
encounter relativity just
includes substituting
the non-relativistic
p to the 4th?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Sorry, I should have said that.
There are other things are
important for relativity
that we'll come to
in a little bit.
But if you just look
at the kinetic energy,
this is the first
non-trivial correction.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we still have
the 2l plus 1 degeneracy.
PROFESSOR: We still have the
2l plus 1 degeneracy, exactly.
Because does this correction
violate rotational invariance?
No, that's p squared.
That's a scalar under rotation.
It's just the
number, not a vector.
But E still commutes with l.
And you see that because this
is independent of little m.
This is the mass
of the electron.
So this is independent of
the quantum number little m.
It only depends on the
quantum number little l.
So indeed, it is
still degenerate.
So let's go through this and
see the degeneracy explicitly.
And let me do that by drawing
you the following diagram.
So what happens if we have
E1, which is the ground state?
It has some energy which is
negative, which is minus E0.
And when we include this first
correction, what does it do?
Well, it decreases
it by some amount.
Everyone cool with that?
It doesn't change the number.
It doesn't split any degeneracy,
because there was only
one ground state
in the first place,
because l had to
be 0 when n is 1.
l has to be one less
than n or smaller.
And if n is 1, l has to be 0.
It can't be any smaller
than 0, so it's 0.
There's just a one state,
with degeneracy 2, 0
plus 1, which is 1.
OK so that's fine.
It just changes the ground
state by some amount.
Let's consider the
second excited level.
So in the second excited
level, we have the states--
and let me name this
slightly differently,
so this has energy minus E0.
The ground state had l
equals 0, and m equals 0.
It had to.
For the second excited
state, n equals 2,
how many states are there?
2 squared is 4, so there are
four states, two, three, four.
And what are their
values of l and m?
Well, if n is 2, l
can be either 0 or 1.
If it's 0, then m has to be 0.
If it's 1, m could be
1, or it could be 0,
or it could be minus 1.
So this, again, is lm, lm, lm.
So those are the four states
with energy E2 in the hydrogen
atom.
And now when we ask, what are
the energies of these three
states, when we include this
so-called fine structure, what
is this going to do?
Well, the ground state is
going to get pushed down
by some amount.
I should draw this differently
to make it more vivid.
This gets pushed down by some
amount, with some value of l.
l here is 0.
But for these
three states, which
all have the same
value of little l, 1,
the denominator is larger.
So the amount by which it
gets pushed down is less.
So these three states
get pushed down less,
but the same amount
as each other.
That cool?
So these three states--
degeneracy is 3,
and this state degeneracy is 1.
Now, notice that 1
plus 3 is equal to 4
is equal to n squared.
So these states split
into multiplets-- groups
of states-- which have
to have the same energy
by rotational invariance.
If they have l
equas 1, there must
be three states with the
same energy-- there must be.
And states with l equals 0,
there's just the one state.
And if we did the
same thing for E3,
let's just think about
what would happen.
So I'm just going
to write the l.
I'm not going to include the m.
We have the l equals 0 times 1.
We have the l equals
1 state, times 3.
And we have l equals 2 state.
And how many states are there
in the l equals 2 state?
Times 5, good.
And again, this gets
pushed down to some value.
This gets pushed
down to some value.
down to some value,
where this is one,
three, and five.
And again, these
add up to 9, which
is 3 squared-- the degeneracy.
So by turning on the
relativistic corrections,
we break this degeneracy.
We lift this degeneracy.
You break the symmetry,
you lift the degeneracy.
Now, unfortunately,
this isn't one
we can control by turning
a dial in the lab.
No experiment that
I can do in the lab
will change the value
of the speed of light.
Well, actually there
are experiments
that will change the value
of the speed of light.
If you work in medium, the
effective speed of light
is different.
So that's going to change
relativistic effects.
So that's interesting.
That tells you that you can
actually vary this continuously
if you can vary continuously
the index of refraction
of the ambient system.
I invite you to think
about how you might do that
experimentally, because
it's a fun question.
OK, however, what
I'd really like
is something where
Professor Evan in his lab
can actually turn a dial,
and change the spectrum
in a way that explicitly
breaks the symmetry.
Meanwhile, I also
want an example
that breaks the
rotational invariance.
I want to break the 2l
plus 1 states up into 2l
plus 1 states with
different energies.
I want to make them
depend on the angular
momentum in some direction.
What must I do in order
to lift that degeneracy?
AUDIENCE: Add a magnetic field.
PROFESSOR: Fantastic.
If you add a magnetic
field, why is that
going to break the degeneracy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Give
me an answer that
depends, not on your
knowledge of chemistry,
but give me an answer that
depends on symmetries.
Why doe turning on
a magnetic field
have the potential to split
the degeneracy of the 2l plus 1
states?
AUDIENCE: You don't have
rotational symmetry.
PROFESSOR: Thank you, exactly.
You have no rotational
symmetry, exactly.
So that's pretty good.
So let's break the 2l plus 1 by
breaking rotational symmetry.
There are many ways we could
break rotational symmetry.
We could turn on
an electric field.
a magnetic field.
We could put a
shovel in the room.
But anything that breaks
rotational symmetry will do it,
but a very convenient way is
to do it with a magnetic field.
Magnetic field is
particularly beautiful.
So this is effect is now
call the Zeeman effect.
I believe it was
Faraday-- one of
the classic electromagnetists
of the 19th century attempted
to look at the spectral
lines coming off glowing gas,
and see if they
changed by turning
on an electric or
a magnetic field.
It turns out to be
a tricky experiment
to do, because you need to
have a very well-controlled
magnetic field,
otherwise what you
get is just a bunch of schmutz.
So to get a clean
spectrum, you have
to have a very uniform magnetic
field, which is not trivial.
It has to be time independent.
So Zeeman, at the very end of
the 19th century-- in fact,
this experiment was
done, I believe, in '96.
So I think the paper
came out in '97
but the experiment
was done in '96.
Zeeman did this experiment.
He said look, if i turn
on a magnetic field
next to a hot, glowing gas
and look the spectrum that
comes off, anything
happen to it?
Why would you think that
anything might happen?
And the answer to this
one is really quite nice.
Look, if we compute
the energy, the energy
is going to be
equal to the Coulomb
energy plus a correction,
which is the following--
if you think of the atom
as an electron that carries
some angular momentum in
the presence of a proton,
if you think of the electron as
a thing carrying some angular
momentum, and a
thing with a charge--
it has a charge and
angular momentum.
It's going to have
magnetic moment, mu.
And the magnetic
moment is going to be
equal to the current of the
charge times the area swept out
divided by c, because we
work with sensible units.
And this is equal to minus--
for the case of the atom--
minus mu, the magnetic
moment of the system
dotted into the magnetic
field that you turn on
in the background.
So this is a background
magnetic field.
I am turning on an
electromagnet, which
induces a magnetic field
in some known direction,
with some known magnitude.
So my dial is the
magnitude of that B field.
I could make it large,
or I could make it small.
And it's in a known direction.
And the point is, our electron
because it's orbiting,
because it carries
some angular momentum
and it carries some in charge,
has some magnetic moment.
So it behaves like
a little bar magnet.
And that bar magnet wants to
anti-align with the background
magnetic field that
I've turned on.
So there's an energy penalty
to not being aligned.
This is the usual dipole-dipole
potential from electrostatics.
OK and mu here is equal to minus
E over 2mc-- angular momentum.
So this can be computed from
a simple model of the atom.
Whatever, it's easy to compute.
So this is slightly
annoying, because if E
is in some arbitrary direction,
let's just simplify our life
and say that's equal to
E Coulomb minus mu B.
And I want to turn on a
magnetic field of known
amplitude in a known direction.
Let's call it the z direction.
So this is mu z.
But this mu z, that's just mu
z is lz times minus E over 2mc.
So this is going to
be plus E over 2mc,
Bz-- I'm going to put
this all together, Bz Lz.
Everyone cool with that?
So where this is
coming from, again,
is just the angular momentum
is telling you the velocity.
The velocity is telling
you the current.
And then the area is the radius.
So that's what's giving you
the radius and the angular
momentum.
So this is our energy.
What does this tell you
about the energy eigenvalues?
They depend on m, right?
And do we have to solve
the energy eigenvalue
equation again?
No, because our energy
eigenfunctions of Ec
are proportional to
ylm, so they're already
eigenfunctions of lz.
So when I take this beast, and
I act on the wave functions
I erased, but on the 1 upon
little r, capital R, sub nl, y
sub lm-- when I act
on the ylm's, this
is just going to give
me h bar m, right?
So this is just a constant when
acting on the Coulomb energy
eigenfunction.
So this is a much
easier problem.
That way, we don't even have
to make any approximations.
We can just say exactly energy
Zeeman is equal to minus E0
upon n squared, nlm
plus E h bar upon 2mc,
Bz-- the background
magnetic field,
and this is the m of electron
mass-- times little m.
And I'm going to write
little m sub l, just
to distinguish little
m sub l from m sub E.
So when we turn
on the prediction
here, when we turn on the
magnetic field a la Zeeman,
our energy levels will
get split according
to the different values of m.
Now if instead of working
with the pure Coulomb system,
if we were in fact
a little clever,
and we'd already noticed that
there's a fine structure--
because they already
knew that there
was a fine structure
at this point--
they could see the
different spectra
in lines coming off of hot gas.
So it's just an
experimental fact
you can't turn off
the fine structure.
This is going to be equal
to e nlm of our correction
to the hydrogen atom, with
the fine structure corrected.
So the l equals 1 states and
the l equals 0 states are split.
Let's focus, for example, on E2.
So these guys have
a different energy.
The l equals 1 guys
have a different energy
than the l equals 0 guys.
What does this predict
is going to happen
if I look at my spectral line?
So what this predicts
is the following--
it says that if you
have some spectrum that
looks like this-- so this is
as a function of wavelength
and i'm looking literally
at what comes off a prism.
I'm looking at spectrum lines.
And I'll have a line here.
And these are going to
be the l equals 0 states.
This is n equals 2.
And then there's the
l equals 1 states.
This is with zero magnetic
field-- Bz equals 0.
If we turn on a magnetic
field, Bz not equal to zero,
what should we see?
Well, what happens
to this state?
Nothing-- it's the same thing,
because the m is strictly 0,
so it's the same value.
And this guy, what
happens to it?
The m equals 0
state is the same.
But then it breaks
up-- as everyone said,
it breaks up into three lines
that are equally spaced.
It breaks up into three
lines, because one of them
has m which is plus 1, one
of them has m which is 0,
and one is m is minus 1.
So energies will
increase or decrease.
Let's say this is frequency.
So we get this splitting.
And another way to draw
this is as a function of B,
let's draw the energy levels.
So there's the 1.
There's the 0.
And this stays constant.
And these guys-- one is
constant, one increases,
and one decreases.
When you start getting into
strong magnetic fields,
weird things happen,
like these guys cross,
and all sorts of subtle
things can happen.
But let's ignore the
strong magnetic field case,
and just focus on this.
So we see that these guys split.
So this is what the Schrodinger
theory, or the full story
would predict-- it came
a little bit after this,
but this experiment
was done in '96,
so there's actually kind of an
entertaining story about people
trying to explain this
effect classically.
Well, look you could
have some angular
momentum in the z
direction, some angular
momentum in the x direction,
some angular momentum in the y
direction.
The part that has angular
momentum in the x direction
doesn't do anything,
or in the z direction.
The part with the x
and part with the y
can have different polars.
There's a whole
classical song and dance.
It's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense.
But that's because they were
trying to classical mechanics
to do quantum mechanics,
which doesn't work.
So I'm not even going
to bother explaining
what they were thinking.
But anyway, so people came up
with a sort of classical crutch
to say, well that's
not totally insane.
So this is what Zeeman
got, for example,
by looking at hydrogen.
But he did more than
just look at hydrogen.
I can't remember exactly-- I
think he did it with sodium.
Matt, do you remember?
I think he did sodium and iron.
But anyway, here's
the funny thing
that he got with
sodium and iron.
So this is a
different experiment.
It's exactly the
same set up, but he
was looking at spectral
lines in sodium.
And spectral lines in sodium
did a very similar thing.
There were some
where 1 went to 1.
And there were
others where 1 went
to-- why did we have three here?
Just as quick reminder, why
do we have three states here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Because we have
three states for l equals 1.
This one state went to one,
two, three, four states,
with none of them in the middle.
And in fact, it's
worse than that,
because they didn't go
to equally spaced states
in general.
In general, they did
something slightly funny.
And the beautiful plot in
his paper looks like this.
There are four states, and as
you take the magnetic field
to 0, these four states
all coalesce exactly
to this one state.
So this one line is representing
four different states.
And this already included
the fine structure,
so we know that this is
all a single value of l.
But that apparently
has four states.
That's should worry you.
What does that tell you about l?
What does l have to
be in order to have
four states in your tower?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Half integer--
in particular, what value?
3/2, crap.
We already know that
these wave functions
are described by
the ylm's, right?
We solved that problem.
We explicitly solved it.
Here's the exact answer.
It's the ylm's.
But we've observed
experimentally
that l has to be 3/2.
But if l is 3/2,
ylm is equal to 0,
because it's equal
to minus itself.
This is bad.
This is 0.
So this effect is called
the Zeeman effect,
and this effect is called
the anomalous Zeeman effect.
[LAUGHTER]
Which is strange
for two reasons.
The first reason it's
strange is they showed up
in the same paper.
And the second thing is, OK,
you call it the Zeeman effect,
because there's some
guy named Zeeman.
Is there some guy
named Anomalous Zeeman?
It's a very strange name.
Anyway so this was called
the anomalous Zeeman effect,
despite appearing in the same
paper, because it's weird.
It was deeply
disconcerting to people.
We now just call it
the Zeeman effect,
but we have the bad habit--
for entertainment value--
of referring to it still as
the anamolous Zeeman effect.
I'm not the only one
responsible for that bad habit.
I'm going to point out that at
the end of this paper-- it's
a totally awesome
paper, by the way-- it's
very readable and short--
he says-- I was looking
at it last night-- it
says, quote possibly
the observed phenomenon
will be regarded
as nothing of any consequence.
OK, so a few years later,
Pauli says the following--
so Pauli says this,
actually, and this is also
totally lovely in Science
from 1946 Pauli was in the US
during the war.
After the war, he was at the
Institute for Advanced Study.
At the Institute for Advanced
Studies, while he was there,
he got the Nobel Prize.
And he gave-- for the
exclusion principle, which
we are about to get to--
and he gave a little spiel,
and it's written up in
this edition of Science.
And he says, quote,
a colleague who
met me strolling
rather aimlessly
in the beautiful
streets of Copenhagen
said to me in a friendly
manner, "You look very unhappy."
Whereupon, I responded fiercely,
"How can one look happy
when he is thinking about
the anamolous Zeeman effect?"
[LAUGHTER]
So this troubled people.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah he found
all sorts of crazy states.
So this isn't the only example.
It's just the only
one I'm going to draw.
But indeed, you can
find five half states
you can find states with six.
AUDIENCE: Why [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I didn't
draw all the states.
The spectrum is complicated
and messy, because it's sodium.
And so there's
all sorts of crap.
So I'm just not drawing it.
I'm just focusing on a
specific set of spectral lines.
Maybe the best way
to draw that is-- OK.
So this was really troubling.
So let's put this on
pause for the moment,
and we'll come back to
it in just a second.
So meanwhile, there's
something else
that's sort of annoying
about this system.
We've got the Coulomb potential,
and the Coulomb potential
has the following
beautiful property--
the degeneracy of any energy
state is equal to n squared.
Meanwhile, various
people were fond
of observing the fact that
the number of states, which
I will-- in an
abuse of language--
call the degeneracy of the
level n in the periodic table,
is equal to-- well, the
first one there's two.
And then there's eight,
and then there's 18.
So two, 8, 8, 18, that's
almost 2n squared.
Two four 8, 9, 18.
Cool, maybe there's a
relationship, right?
And meanwhile,
it's very tempting
to think there's a
relationship, because imagine
you have four electrons.
If you have four electrons,
what you do you do?
Well, you put an
electron here, and then
you could put an
electron here, or you
could put an other
electron here.
You could also put another
electron here and here.
Or you could put them
in any combination-- two
here, put two here,
two here, one,
one-- you could do all
sorts of stuff, right?
But if, for the
moment, you imagine
that electrons have
this funny property.
Imagine for a moment
that electrons
have the property that they
can't be in the same state
at once.
Then if you have four
electrons-- I don't know why.
I'm desperate.
I'm thinking about the
anamolous Zeeman effect,
among other things.
I have nothing better to do.
So just for fun, let's imagine
if I put an elector here,
I can't put another one.
So if I have a
two electron atom,
the second one goes
with one of these.
A three-electron atom,
a four-electron atom,
and these guys are all related
to each other, because they
live in the same
energy level, but they
have different l
values, so they'll
have slightly
different properties.
That suggests that
the one l equals
0 state should be different
from the 3 l equals 1 states,
chemically.
But wait-- there aren't
groupings of one and three.
They're groupings
of two and six.
Ah, two-- well, so Pauli
staring at this in 1925
said the following--
he said, look,
I'm going to
conjecture two things.
The first is that
no two electrons
can live in the same state--
inhabit the same quantum state.
That doesn't give us the
periodic table, though.
It gives us half
the periodic table.
There are twice as many states
in hydrogen as you think.
And you might think that
I'm being facetious,
that he said something a
little more sophisticated.
But he really didn't.
What he said is, I
posit of the existence
of an additional quantum number
which the electron can have,
which takes one of two values.
Which translated, says, there
are twice as many states
as you think.
So that's exactly what he said.
So this is called the
Pauli exclusion principle.
And now this does a
totally spectacular thing--
and you've probably all seen
this in high school chemistry,
or even college chemistry.
Now, first electron goes
here, second electron
goes here, because there
are twice as many states
as you think, but then I can't
put another state in there,
because that's as
many as you can have.
One can go here, and you
can put up to six in here.
And that's it.
So the E2 states, the n squared,
which is 4 times 2 states,
are somehow related to
each other naturally.
And this gives you the
structure of the periodic table.
In fact, an awful
lot of chemistry
follows directly from this.
So this is the Pauli
exclusion principle.
However, it's a little
bit disappointing,
because while this is
whatever-- some ridiculous rule,
but we're doing
quantum mechanics
and they're all
ridiculous rules.
On the other hand, this
one is just stupid.
Right?
This is just, like, look,
it wouldn't it be nice?
So in '25, a couple guys--
really interesting characters--
named Goudsmit and Uhlenbeck--
so Uhlenbeck-- wow,
we're really low on time.
OK, so I'll just tell
you this, and then I'll
get to the last of it later.
So Goudsmit and Uhlenbeck--
who were young, kind of naive--
said, look we've got
two effects here.
One effect is the
anamolous Zeeman effect,
and there's this
weird fact that states
have the wrong total
angular momentum.
And we have this second
thing, that there are twice
as many states for
an electron as you
think in the Coulomb potential.
How can these two things
fit together naturally?
Well here's a guess--
suppose that the angular
momentum that we
calculated when we
did the estimate of the braking
due to the Zeeman effect,
suppose that angular momentum
was not the right angular
momentum.
Maybe there's more angular
momentum in the system.
There's angular momentum in
the system from the electron
orbiting around, but maybe
like a little, tiny Earth,
the electron itself can
have some intrinsic angular
momentum.
It turns out Pauli had
had this idea before.
In fact, Kramers
had suggested this
to him, who was a very
young guy at the time.
And Pauli said, you're
a blithering idiot,
because if you calculate
how small an electron has
to be in order to fit all the
other things we know, and you
figure out how fast it would
have to rotate to explain
the anamolous Zeeman
effect, the surface
would have to be moving
faster the speed of light.
That's ridiculous.
Leave my office.
So then Uhlenbeck and Goudsmit--
these two guys-- write a paper,
and say aha!
Well, we can explain
this, but let's just not
assume that the stupid
thing is rotating.
Let's just say an electron
has some intrinsic angular
momentum.
I don't know, why not?
Electrons have intrinsic
angular momentum,
and if you assume that electrons
have an intrinsic angular
momentum-- which I'll call
S for the moment-- so then
the total angular
momentum, j, is
equal to l, its orbital
angular momentum,
plus some intrinsic
angular momentum, which--
I don't remember what symbol
they used, but we'll call it
for the moment S-- where
this has the property that S
squared, for an electron,
sorry, the principle quantum
number, which I will call
little s is equal to 1/2,
so m sub s is equal
to plus or minus 1/2.
So this is like the l equals
1/2 state, but it's not l.
It's something intrinsic.
It has nothing to do
with anything rotating.
It's just a fact
about electrons.
Suppose electrons have
a little bit of spin.
Then what you discover is if
you have the l equals 1 state,
and the electron
has spin 1/2, what's
the total angular momentum?
3/2, right?
So what do you get?
You get quadruplets, like that.
So this turns out to
explain-- if you include
a small relativistic
effect-- this turns out
to explain the anomalous
Zeeman effect bang on.
Meanwhile, there
was an experiment
done in 1922, which is the
Stern-Gerlach experiment,
in which Stern and Gerlach
discovered that nickel, when
sent through a magnetic
field gradient,
bent into one of two
different spots-- never three,
never zero, always two.
How can that be?
Electron spin-- that
wasn't realized until 1929,
that the connection was there.
So these guys came up with
this ridiculous postulate.
This was Uhlenbeck and Goudsmit.
And let me just quickly--
U-H-L-E-N-B-E-C-K--
so Uhlenbeck-- amazing,
amazing scientist,
also the father of the
mathematician Uhlenbeck,
and she was a total badass,
and has inspired an awful lot
of physics-- Karen
Uhlenbeck, who's at UT.
So this is a pretty
interesting and prolific guy.
But he was also prolific
in the following way--
he ran a program at the Rad
Lab at MIT during World War II.
And Goudsmit worked with him.
And when they were finishing
up, when the war was ending,
Goudsmit became the scientific
adviser to something
called Project Alsos.
Project Alsos was a project
where the military went
to the conquered
territories in Germany
to catch the German
atomic scientists,
and bring them to a
place called Farm Hall
in England, where they listened
and eavesdropped on them--
Heisenberg, all the good guys.
Well, bad guys-- it depends
on-- all the great physicist
in the German
territory at the time
were deeply complicated people.
And they listened to them.
Something called the
Farm Hall Transcripts
are the transcripts
of those recordings.
They were written up in a book
called "The Epsilon Project,"
which is totally
breathtakingly awesome.
And Goudsmit wrote a
book called "Alsos"
about this process of hunting
down the German scientists.
So Goudsmit,
G-O-U-D-S-M-I-T, I think,
he wrote a book called "Alsos",
which I heartily recommend
to you, because it's like a
combination adventure story
and beautiful bit
of physics history.
So these guys both were at
MIT during the World War.
So there's a nice
connection here.
So these guys--
fascinating characters,
and they came up with this
idea of some intrinsic angular
momentum.
Pauli then calls it spin.
He gives it the name.
And he develops a
mathematical theory of spin.
And the mathematical
theory of spin
will lead to quantum field
theory, relativistic quantum
mechanics, and will
eventually lead
to quantum computation,
which is going
to be the topic of the
last week of our course.
So what we've done
so far is we've
explained the discreteness
of atomic spectra,
and we've explained
the structure
of the periodic table.
What we haven't
done, is we haven't
explained why atoms form
molecules or solids.
And we also haven't explained
what spin is at all.
Those are the topics in
the next three weeks.
See you next time.